well you demanded it so here it is my
newest cosplay video I present to you
moon night jazz kidding last people care
about that guy than Deadpool in 2008
will make you extremely mainstream and
overexposed to the mass media one day
Spectre one day for now though even
though I struggle like hell not to be a
spider-man Channel you just keep pulling
me back in so let's get down to it you
all want to know about a man named Riley
Ben Riley is the less well-off clone of
spider-man that made everyone very angry
in the 90s for being a dumb concept he
lived in squalor and made a costume for
himself with like $50 so I've
affectionately named this one grunge
rock hobo spider-man for those who
suffered through my last two cosplay
tutorials you know the drill by now get
our usual supplies ready red morphsuit
separate masks fabric glue that stuff
you put on the edges of cloth after
cutting it so it doesn't fray like crazy
and probably some alcohol to ease the
troubled soul of your emotionally
distraught mother who has to constantly
help you with these god-awful cosplay
projects at the expense of her free time
and sanity usual supplies so for the red
suit you just oh well jeez that's pretty
easy then you don't have to do anything
this design is so simple just put it on
and it's ready well that's a lot of
steps removed from that other crap good
thing I didn't pick Kayne Souter I'd
have to color the entire head and
shoulders and black paint while wearing
it so the next step is to take a blue
hoodie provided by your uncle on a
scenario in which he was like hey here's
a bunch of clothes that don't fit me
anymore I brought them in several large
trash bags so you could maybe use some
of it for a cosplay or something and
then you respond accordingly with but
drew I can you only use maybe two
articles of clothing in here for
something the rest are just taking up a
ton of space and you clearly found it
easier to just dump all this on me
instead of driving a few extra minutes
to the local goodwill you lazy Punk
and it'll be like yeah basically make
sure you say all of that to the very
letter if either you or your uncle
mispronounce a word the costume won't
work anyway at least I got the blue
hoodie but as it turns out there's a bit
of a scaling difference between my uncle
and I do to my faulty Irish genetics
that spilled into my bloodline at some
point in the last few centuries of
heritage as such I got to modify this
hoodie a bit to get it to look right
first I cut it in half so could have
that grungy 90s Bill and Ted crop top
look because skater culture and heavy
metal became big motifs when Todd and
Rob took the industry by storm an
indirectly almost bankrupted Marvel TV
allure to the max bro tell you pin parts
of the hoodie together to make it fit a
little smaller sew it together with the
trusty sewing machine you probably stole
and then cut the excess fabric out near
the seams that you've created now of
course a lot of clothes have these darn
brand logos on them so you'll know which
middle-eastern sweatshop put it together
20 years later this one isn't a decal or
printed on or something easy this thing
is intricately woven into the fabric and
requires a ton of effort to remove thus
you get a thing called a stitch Ripper
and stip some riches I can't remember if
I'm recalling the process I did or
instructing you to do these things
anymore so the language changes every
other sentence even though no one will
care or notice except me hey for all of
you whiny technology age kids that got
offended by my use of a camera from 2009
I used all of my graduation money to buy
a 4k camera so you'd stop telling me I
recorded all of these on a potato I
could have used that money to buy food
but I used it to please you resolution
obsessed basket cases the video
compression on YouTube sucks anyway so
you can't even tell us 4k so like who
cares about anything life is meaningless
now you can't apply the spider logo with
a marker by free-handing it but I wanted
to be a little more thorough and make
sure it was just right I printed one out
from Google Image Search and cut it out
of a piece of flimsy cardboard with an
x-acto knife step 11 once you've created
a stencil for your logo and completely
inappropriate conditions come to the
realization that you've made a giant
mistake
step 14 stir the red velvet mix in a
bowl until it's finally nice and viscous
place the mix into separate sections of
a cupcake sheet and bake at 450 degrees
once you've stayed up until 5 a.m. on a
school night making apology cupcakes for
your mother after carving a giant spider
logo into her expensive kitchen table
you're ready to paint the hoodie I found
this nice black fabric paint at that
store for old ladies that I always look
weird hanging out in whoa demonetised
sorry everyone I didn't know this paint
brand was racist expect a half-hearted
apology video in two to three business
days so I kept the stencil firmly in
place on the hoodie and used a
paintbrush to apply it
nor more of that spray paint stuff I'm
done with that noise thankfully the
hoodie was thick enough that the paint
didn't bleed through it also dried
rather quickly
this stuff's great and now you're done
oh yeah uh siree so he can sell more
toys got it making Ben Riley's
web-shooters can go a number of ways I
took some elastic and a belt from
Walmart to do the next step I used some
silver puff paint to coat the elastic
after cutting it to fit snugly around my
wrist the paint makes it pretty rigid
but it'll still stretch attach them
together both ends with the sewing
machine the web cartridge is I bought a
huge pack of Nerf darts and
spray-painted them most people will tell
you to wear protective gear over your
mouth and eyes during spray painting but
I can't afford any of that stuff so I
just try not to inhale too much paint
sometimes the air coming out of the can
pushes the darts too hard and they roll
away because they're made of super light
foam it's very annoying
I used this straw from a soda from
Arby's to prod the darts around and
rotate them without touching the paint
with my hands which gave me the idea to
make it the nozzle on the web-shooter
there's like a red dot thingy on the
belt buckle so I made a stencil the size
of a quarter painted on there I tried to
use fabric paint on metal at first like
a complete idiot and then it bled
through the masking tape ah god damn it
then I meticulously scrubbed all the
paint off to try it again white has been
Riley have a red button on his belt
buckle you may ask no reason that's just
the way they drew them sometimes it's
not even there all right hot glue the
web cartridges on the belt in the
elastic don't burn yourself not that you
listen to anything I say
okay now for the big important part the
mask from what I can tell right lobe
ends mask always has way bigger lenses
than his counterpart
I took my friend Andres advice in order
to pair these pre-made ones to use for a
Miles Morales suit let's pick up our
trusty spandex rag and get ready to
mangle it in the name of cosplay these
new lenses are made of like plastic and
plywood or something so don't drill any
holes in them just be very thorough
about gluing them well the mask is kind
of shaped weird now because these lenses
stretch it in such an odd way now the
outline of my mouth is super easy to see
just like Jenn Miley's other terrible
costume that he got rid of immediately
because it sucked so bad I also think I
kind of screwed up with the mask because
there's no space between my eyes and the
lenses so it's like hard to blink it's
touching my eyeball huh
note to self stick with what you know
never experiment not gonna lie I don't
really recommend these lenses I'm not
happy enough with the look to justify
the difficulty of working with them but
if you can figure out a way to make it
look good then give it a try
well that was much like the character
itself underwhelming let's spice this
one up a little and do another one
this costume video is going into
overtime since the theme of today is
people that have no discernible
differences from Peter Parker in any way
here's an unrelated picture of Miles
Morales oh I'm just kidding he's alright
actually like his costume more than
Peter Parker's because the red and black
color scheme so let's give that a shot
but Xavier you can't cosplay a character
who doesn't have the same skin color as
you even though no skin is visible in
the cosplay that's racist
oh I'm sorry small child turns out
you're not allowed to like or enjoy
things that look different from you this
character wasn't made for you you're
going to have to wear the politically
correct spider-man costume excuse me sir
but that costume is for a character that
looks different I'm afraid I'm going to
have to ask you to change you know I I
hate this awful world for making me get
political but one of you Schmucks was
gonna bring it up if I didn't address it
yeah anyway while I did most of the
heavy lifting on the last one this suit
will have to rely heavily on the help of
my tired and disenfranchised assistant
from homes loins my curse it exists
spawned since I don't have a mannequin
let alone one in my size all the
painting work will have to be while I'm
wearing the damn thing again so for the
big red stripes masking tape and fabric
paint will do you fine thankfully it's
not as complex a pattern is that other
nightmare so the lines on this one are
really straight and the paint is kind of
glossy if you were making a spider-man
homecoming cosplay I'd recommend using
this method for all those extraneous
black lines after that just kind of wing
it on the webs they're kind of hard to
screw up plus with the paint being
applied like frosting to a cake and has
this 3d effect to it that looks better
than just drawing it with markers of
course I recommend doing the rough draft
of them with like a sharpie or something
first then you can just kind of print
out the logo trace the outline of it and
go nuts the paint is of course going to
be on you for like three weeks but the
results are pretty cool I watched Point
Break with David for an episode of his
show couch potatoes while doing the webs
on the back you might see that video at
some point in the next three years the
mask should be easy we made a ton of
these by now in other videos for more on
that go check these out I had a friend
paint them red for me with probably
spray paint or whatever I didn't really
ask questions I just sort of rolled up
to his house in the middle of the night
you ran them out to me on the street
like it was some kind of drug deal so I
don't really know what he did to them oh
yeah put some masking tape over the
shiny part first so now you got a mask
with red outlines on the thing
thankfully a foam mannequin head is
actually pretty easy to find
so no red grid on my face today just do
it how you did the body silver lines
first red lines second should go okay be
sure to use an action figure as a
reference so you know how the pattern is
meant to fit over a 3-dimensional object
some artists have a tendency to cut
corners or draw it in a way that's not
honest to how it would really look so
you can't trust every picture you get on
google image search so the logo on the
back I wanted to try something a little
different we painted the pattern out on
a piece of parchment paper that was
partially translucent then let it dry
overnight the thing peeled off
surprisingly easily and was totally
intact at the end
the paint was even strong enough that
you could tug on it and stretch it a
little in the logo wouldn't you tear so
we glued that onto the back with rubber
cement which actually burns like crazy
so just use fabric glue the fingers were
pretty easy just paint them with a
spongy brush I have really long fingers
though so I had to wear it to tape off
the parts correctly because the fabric
needs to stretch the right way so then
uh yeah I guess that's it all right
I enjoy going as miles for conventions
just remember not to take the mask off
if your complexion matches mine because
you'll probably get some dirty looks
maybe from now on I should diversify my
cosplays a little more for every six
spider-man suits I have like one moon
night how about you fellas in the
comments tell me about some non
spider-man characters I could also make
cosplays for in the meantime I got to
get me a plate of chicken wings
[Music]
and what the hell are you doing out here
uh duh I'm Nick Fury director of shield
I'm here to tell you about the Avengers
initiative
I don't remember Nick Fury being a
member of the Backstreet Boys captain
crop-top well you know Dawg I'm just
picking up some dank ass chicken wings
Holmes I got the munchies like a monkey
no I'm saying for sheezy money Z it
ain't easy P and cheese hey don't
distract me with my love of Ebonics who
are you extremely white person
well Xavier it's time I told you the
truth you're my clone Shirley before we
started this YouTube channel you and I
had a chance encounter that turned into
combat during our epic battle we became
swapped unclear as to which of us was
the real Xavier after our first meeting
I assumed I was the clone and left to go
live a life on the road eating hugh's
sandwiches out of dumpsters in the city
while you became a z-list internet
celebrity any questions
how do you use a sandwich without eating
it all so if I'm the one who started
YouTube channel aren't I the more like
successful and interesting one why come
back and ruin everything oh well I
actually just show up here every couple
of days to steal food from your freezer
dick if you continue this conversation
you'll disrupt the timestream well are
you I'm the half Hispanic guy with the
black and red costume and a father with
a dark secret that takes your place
after you die so miles who howdy
okay are you guys serious come on this
guy's a total knockout what's your deal
oh you know the usual wealth and fame
I'm ignored action is my reward what you
mean like the affirmative kind I want to
be exactly like that guy when I grow up
like like 100 percent no deviations and
personality at all I'll make sure that
doesn't happen you surfer kill them all
only the one true and see here can rule
the YouTube channel I am the one true
replacement and/or original
[Music]
[Music]